ZDF heute live schön dass ihr mit dabei
seid die Kämpfe zwischen den Hamas
Terroristen und Israel die gehen weiter
die israelischen Bodentruppen im
gazastifen wurden gestern nach eigenen
Angaben verstärkt offiziell als
Bodenoffensive bezeichnet Israel die
Einsätze aber nicht wohl auch aus
taktischen Gründen israels
Ministerpräsident Benjamin nanu sprach
stattdessen am Wochenende vom Beginn
einer zweiten Phase des Krieges auch die
Angriffe aus der Luft mit Kampfjets und
Drohnen auf Ziele im Gazastreifen die
wurden deutlich verstärkt viele in
Israel die sehen die israelischen
Militärschläge aber kritisch und
fürchten um die Geiseln die immer noch
in den Händen der Hamas sind das
israelische Militär hat ihre Zahl
gestern nach oben korrigiert auf mehr
als
230 wie könnten diese Geiseln befreit
werden wie geht das israelische Militär
dabei strategisch vor und ist die
gegenwärtige strateg sinnvoll und wie
sieht die israelische Bevölkerung die
militärischen Operationen darüber wollen
wir heute sprechen und zwar gleich mit
dem Sicherheitsexperten Gerhard Konrad
der selbst einmal zwischen der Hamas und
Israel vermittelt hat und wir schalten
vorher zu unserem ZDF Reporter Luk
waltoop nach Tel Aviv um über die
aktuelle Situation der G der Geiseln zu
sprechen und auch über mögliche
Verhandlung für euch gilt wie immer eure
Fragen und Gedanken zum Thema könnt ihr
direkt gerne hier im Chat stellen oder
ihr schickt sie uns per Mail an die
Mailadresse
zdfheute-life@zdf.de jetzt wollen wir
über eine ganz aktuelle Geschichte
sprechen und zwar kam gerade die Meldung
dass das israelische Militär nach
eigenen Angaben eine Geisel und zwar
eine Soldatin in der vergangenen nachts
befreien konnte die in den Gasastreifen
verschleppt worden war ihr seht jetzt
hier gerade das Foto das vom offiziellen
israelischen Account gepostet wurde bei
X da sehen wir sie auch schon mit ihrer
Familie zusammen den Angaben den
israelischen Angaben zufolge geht es ihr
gesundheitlich gut über die Befreiung
dieser Geisel und die Situation der
anderen Geisel möchte ich jetzt sprechen
mit meinem Kollegen l waltop der ist mir
jetzt aus Tel Aviv zugeschaltet hallo
l guten Abend hol uns bitte einmal gerne
ab was weiß man was ist zur Zeit bekannt
über die Befreiung dieser
Soldaten sehr wenig der
Verteidigungsminister ist gerade vor die
Presse gegangmen er hat keine operativen
Details bekannt gegeben wie unter
welchen Umständen man diese Soldatin
befreit hat er hat nur den Zeitpunkt
genannt es war bei den Operationen
letzte Nacht und also im Gazastreifen
und es handelt sich offenbar um eine
Soldatin die
am Überfall der Hamas am 7 Oktober
Dienst tat auf einem der
Beobachtungsposten direkt an der Grenze
die also den grenzzaau gewissermaßen
beobachtet hat und dann verschleppt
wurde von Hamas wie gesagt wir haben
keine Details aber der
Verteidigungsminister klang sehr
energisch hat gesagt das ist ein gutes
Zeichen ein gutes Ergebnis unserer
Arbeit doch die wir fortsetzen wollen
das heißt man wird weiter mit
Bodentruppen versuchen in Gaza auch
Geiseln aufzuspüren und
selbstverständlich kommandoeinrichtungen
und auch Kämpfer der Hamas zu
eliminieren lü dann lass uns gerne
einmal auch auf die Situation der
anderen Geiseln schauen ich habe es
gesagt es sind noch israelischen Angaben
mehr als 230 die immer noch in der aft
der herassind ihre Situation ist aktuell
völlig unklar aber im Fall der deutschen
Shani Luke gibt es seit heute traurige
Gewissheit sie wurde von den Hamas
verschleppt nun hat das israelische
Militär ihren Tod mitgeteilt mehr gibt's
von meinem Kollegen fedatigöz da schauen
wir einmal
rein Freunde und Familie von Shani Luk
vor rund zwei Wochen in Tel Aviv beim
Besuch von Kanzler schreuzz in Israel
dort hatten sie noch die Hoffnung dass
sie am Leben ist doch heute die traurige
gewisshit
die 23jährige deutsch israeliin ist tot
die Familie und auch die deutsche
Botschaft in Israel bestätigen dass ihm
Zusammenhang mit dem brutalen Angriff
der hamasterroristen am 7 Oktober ums
Leben
kam ich empfinde auf der einen Seite
Traurigkeit weil es keine Chance gibt
dass sie zurückkommt auf der anderen
Seite gibt es jetzt Gewissheit was mit
ihr passiert ist sie hat wahrscheinlich
nicht gelitten und ist ziemlich am
Anfang
gestorben Luke war beim Überfall der
Hammers auf ein Musikfestival entführt
und verschleppt worden seitdem galt sie
als vermisst Bundeskanzler Scholz
bezeichnete die Ermordung von shaniny
Luke als furchtbare Tat und
Barberei l es sind noch ich habe es
gerade gesagt mehr als 230 Geiseln in
den Händen der Hamas was weißt du über
die was ist darüber bekannt wie es denen
gerade geht und wo Sie sich
befinden wenn die israelischen Behörden
und die Armee darüber Informationen hat
dann teilen Sie uns der Presse also das
nicht mit aus taktischen Gründen wir
wissen also genau genommen sehr wenig
die Zahl die letzte Zahl die im Raum
steht des 239 davon sollen viele einen
ausländischen Pass haben übrigens z.B
auch mehrere Dutzend wie es heißt
aus Thailand das waren Saisonarbeiter
die auf Farmen unten neben dem
Gazastreifen gearbeitet haben und die
beim über der Hamas mitgenommen wurden
also man weiß wenig auch wo sie sich
aufhalten wissen wir nicht es ist
anzunehmen dass sie im ausgebreiteten
Tunnelsystem unter Gaza sich befinden
aber wir wissen dass heute ein Video
veröffentlicht wurde von Hamas in den
drei Frauen zu sehen sind eine davon
spricht auf Hebräisch und
hat scharfe Kritik an Ministerpräsident
Netanyahu geäußert und gefordert
Netanyahu möge jetzt sofort diese
Geiseln und zwar alle gegen etwa mehr
als 5000 palästinensische Häftlinge in
israelischer Haft
austauschen aber da hat der
Ministerpräsident in einer
Pressekonferenz die gerade zu Ende
gegangen ist noch mal betont dass ein
grausames Spiel das die amast da treibe
mit Geiseln die sich nicht dagegen
wehren können mit Zivilisten und man
werde diese Vorschläge ganz sicher nicht
befolgen und keinen geiselaustausch
vornehmen unter solchen Bedingungen man
fordert nach wie vor sofortige
Freilassung aller Geisel
dieses Video was du gerade angesprochen
hast von den drei Geiseln das macht
heute die Runde und wird viel diskutiert
lass uns gerne noch einmal auf die
Situation in Israel schauen wir haben
dazu eine Frage bekommen bei Youtube die
lautet wie kontrovers werden die
befreiungsbemühung bzw auch die
Situation der Geiseln logischerweise
innenpolitisch in Israel
diskutiert das ist ein ganz großes Thema
es hat auch damit zu tun dass der
Ministerpräsident netanahu selbst sehr
stark in der Kritik steht hat viel mit
den politischen Auseinandersetzungen vor
diesem Krieg zu tun aber es gibt so
einfach einen großen Teil in der
Gesellschaft hier der der Ansicht ist
dass Netanyahu der falsche Mann ist und
ganz sicher in diesem Krieg am falschen
Platz und dass er zurücktreten sollte
jetzt kommen wir zu den Geiseln nicht
nur die Familien und die Angehörigen der
Geisen auch weite Teile der Gesellschaft
hier finden das hätte oberste Priorität
vor jedem kriegerischen Gebaren drüben
im Gazastreifen müsste erst sich
gestellt werden dass die Geisen Leben
zurückkommen erst dann könnne man sich
der militärischen Operation widmen äh
die Regierung ist da nicht so eindeutig
sie sagt ja wir tun weiterhin alles um
die Geiseln lebend frei zuekommen heißt
konkret es wird auch weiter verhandelt
über den
über den mittelsmannkanal Qatar und die
Amerikaner sind da auch beteiligt aber
die Operationen die militärischen im
Gazastreifen also insbesondere in
gasastadt im Norden gehen trotzdem
weiter soweit lüg waltop live aus Tel
Aviv zu den aktuellen Entwicklungen
walpot entschuldige bitte so jetzt habe
ich es richtig beim dritten Mal zu den
aktuellen Entwicklungen und der
Situation der Geiseln im Gazastreifen
danke dir für den
Moment ja die israelische Führung die
befindet sich in dieser Situation in
einem Dilemma auf der einen Seite die
Rücksichtnahme auf die Geiseln und die
Zivilbevölkerung die humanitäre Lage im
Gazastreifen die spitzt sich weiter
dramatisch zu und gleichzeitig verfolgt
die israelische Führung weiter das Ziel
die Hamas zu zerschlagen das wollen wir
jetzt noch weiter vertiefen und zwar mit
Gerhard Konrad er hat gut 30 Jahre lang
für den Bundesnachrichtendienst
gearbeitet und war Vermittler in
Verhandlung zu Geiselbefreiung bekannt
wurde er vor allem durch seine
Vermittlung zwischen Israel und der
herrm dabei ging es um die Freilassung
des israelischen Soldaten gilard schalid
der nach 5 Jahren im Austausch gegenüber
1000 palästinensische Gefangene
freikam und Herr Konrad ist mir jetzt
zugesch t wenn ihr euch fragt warum ein
Handy am Hort wir haben hier leider ein
paar technische Probleme mit dem Ton
bitten das an dieser Stelle zu
Entschuldung und ich hoffe trotzdem dass
Herr Konrad mich jetzt hören kann hallo
Herr
Konrad verstehen und ich hoffe Sie
können mich auch hören ich hö sie gut
super perfekt wunderbar ja Herr Konrad
wie schätzen Sie die aktuelle Situation
der Geiseln im gaserastreifen
ein schwierig gefährdet aber nicht
hoffnungslos es ist ganz klar man sieht
es ja auch bei der Befreiung die der
einzelnen Soldatin ähm es sind die die
Geisel sind auf verschiedenste Orte
verteilt äh und vielleicht auch nur in
Einzelpersonen oder kleinsten Gruppen
Hamas hat ein Interesse daran sie vor
Schäden durch die Kriegshandlungen zu
schützen allein schon aus eigen
Interesse weil sie mit den Geisel
natürlich viel vorhat es sind 240
gilchalit wenn Sie es mal ganz
vereinfacht sagen wollen damit kann man
wenn man den Krieg überlebt und das ist
natürlich die fest Absicht von Hammers
dieses auch politisch zu tun kann man
dann zu umfassenden Verhandlungen und
natürlich auch Erpressungen Israels
nutzen das ist der Plan das war der Plan
und dieser Plan ist bis heute nach allem
was wir erkennen können auch an
Kommunikation
öffentlicher Kommunikation der
hamasführung einschließlich der
hamasführung in Gaza auch nicht
aufgegeben Herr konr wir haben es ja
jetzt schon zweimal gesehen dass jeweils
zwei Geiseln freigelassen wurden in den
vergangenen Wochen was ist konkret das
Ziel bzw das Kalkül der Heras hinter
diesen Aktionen diese Aktion zusammen
auch mit dem heutigen Video das kann man
durch im Kontext sehen ist maximalen
Druck in Israel aufzubauen und
gegebenfalls auch weltweit aber in
Israel besonders
sie zeigt has zeigt erstens wir haben
sie zweitens wir sind bereit sie
durchaus auch freizugeben in Klammer
wenn die Bedingungen stimmen und die
Geiseln die bisher entlassen worden sind
haben auch
festgestellt dass sie nach der
Gefangennahme manierlich behandelt
worden sind jedenfalls ist das das was
wir in der Öffentlichkeit gehört haben
auch die Soldatin die jetzt befreit
worden ist hat sich ja wohl dem
Vernehmen nach in einem Gott se loben
dank guten Zustand befunden das zeugt
auch davon aus her
maßsicht im Grunde machen wir das so wie
bei Gil Chalid vor 12 Jahren auch der
war in einem manierlichen Zustand nicht
also an uns Hamas soll es nicht liegen
es liegt ausschließlich an der Regierung
n
die uns bekämpft und die die Geisel eben
nicht freilassen also uns dran hindtert
die Geisel freiulassen aber das bedeutet
wenn ich ihn zuhöre dass für viele
Geisel und die vor allem die die dann
nicht das Glück haben bei solchen
Aktionen freigelassen zu werden dass
denen möglicherweise noch eine lange
Gefangenschaft bevorsteht richtig das
steht zu befürchten die israelische
Armee ich habe es e gesagt die weitet
ihre Angriffe im Moment aus zum einen
auf dem Boden zum anderen auch aus der
Luft was bedeutet dieses Vorgehen KR für
die Geiseln im gaserstreifen is sie
ausweiten ist ein weiter und
unbestimmter Begriff es ist ganz klar
die israelischen Streitkräfte gehen
Schritt für Schritt vor das heißt Sie
können auch gar nicht anders als Schritt
für Schritt vorgehen angesichts der
taktischen Lage das heißt es bleibt
normalerweise Zeit genug für Hamas wenn
nötig Geiseln aus exponierten Positionen
auch zurückzuziehen und damit wieder
vorläufig zu sichern
das ist wahrscheinlich dass das hab was
machen wird einfach wie ich schon sagte
aus ihrem eigenen Interesse
heraus wie realistisch ist es denn wir
haben jetzt gesehen es ist in der
vergangene Nacht gelungen diese soldaen
zu befreien das weitere soll das weitere
Geiseln durch eben militärische
Operationen in nah Zukunft freikommen
wie schätzen Sie das ein da es wäre
wichtig hier natürlich ein bisschen mehr
Details zu wissen unter welchen
Umständen jetzt die junge Dame
freigekommen ist od wie sie befreit
worden ist das kann je nachdem wie wie
Geiseln verteilt worden sind
möglicherweise ist sie verlassen worden
dass die hamasis die Flucht ergriffen
haben nicht einfach hinterlassen haben
das wären wichtige Elemente oder war es
wirklich ein aktiver Zugriff der so
geschickt war dass die Geisel e in der
Tat nicht zu Schaden gekommen ist das
kann im Einzelfall immer wieder
passieren aber reines Lotteriespiel da
können wir als Außenstehende überhaupt
nichts Vernünftiges zu sagen die
israelische Armee die hat jetzt immer
wieder gemeldet ranghohe Vertreter der
Hamas töt zu haben aber offenbar haben
die Hamas als Reaktion anders als Sie es
vielleicht mal angekündigt hatten bisher
keine Geiseln getötet wie ist das
einzuschätzen ja hochrangig ist auch ein
relativer Begriff natürlich waren das
wenn Sie wollen Kommandeure
aber die sind dazu da zu kämpfen und ich
sag's etwas gemein nicht war eben dann
auch zu fallen gegenüber den fein
deswegen wird man nicht Geiseln
ostentativ töten sie müssten das ja auch
vorher angekündigt nicht haben oder
jetzt zumindest als eine Reaktion
nehmen das sind die Verluste die im
Krieg auch aus has Sicht erstmal
hinzunehmen sind die Geiseln werden für
besseres
aufgespart sie sind ich habe es eang
schon gesagt natürlich absoluter
Fachmann wenn es darum geht
diplomatische Lösung zu finden bzw zu
vermitteln über die militärischen
Operation haben wir jetzt gesprochen
lassen un dann einmal auf diplomatische
Möglichkeiten schauen wie viel Spielraum
welchen Raum für Verhandlung sehen sie
da gegenwärtig
gegenwärtig letzten Endes nur Gespräche
über z.B eine vorfristige Freilassung
eines Teils der Geiseln also z.B Frauen
Kinder Kranke
das wäre sinnvoll auch unter dem Aspekt
das Hamas wie soll man sagen die
Fürsorge ja die ja durchaus aufwendig
ist für diesen Personenkreis los würde
und wenn man das auf mehrere Dutzend
Personen schätzen würde dann wäre das
etwas Wasus herß im Gegenzug zu einer
taktischen Erleichterung im auf dem
kegschauplatz z.B anbieten könnte oder
für zusätzliche humanitäre Hilfe für die
Bevölkerung den das ist für Herm auf
Dauer auch kein Zustand dass eben die
Bevölkerung oberirdisch wegstirbt sage
ich jetzt mal oder eben katastrophale
noch katastrophalere Verhältnisse
geschehen das kann auch im
Eigeninteresse von am Maß nicht sein sie
wissen sie haben bestimmt gehört dass ja
schon die letzten Tage wenn nicht eine
Woche oder mehr über Qatar solche
Gespräche gelaufen se sein sollen
wie weit die gedienen sind und ob sie
sogar mal zu einem taktisch
überraschenden Durchbruch kommen da das
kann passieren das hängt von der
taktischen Lage dem taktischen Druck
auch ab unter dem sich Hamas selbst
fühlt und ob es die Chance sieht durch
eine solche Freilassung ein Teil des
militärischen Drucks von sich zu nehmen
aber sonst gibt es ja keinen Austausch
es gibt ja keinen Austausch
keino keinen Gegenwert den Hamas hätte
ja für die Freilassung und die
ultimative Zielrichtung ist weiterhin
die entlehrung der israelischen
Gefängnisse das ist klar das kommt äh
nach Einstellung der Kampfhandlung dann
immer das auch ist Herr Konrad ich würde
gerne noch eine Frage an Sie weitergeben
die uns
erreicht hat von einem User und zwar
lautet sie ist es denn überhaupt möglich
die Hamas zu zerschlagen deren Ideologie
lebt doch weiter sie kennen die Heras
sehr gut was sagen sie dazu ja ich meine
es ist nur nicht nur die Ideologie die
weiterlebt ähm es wird durch diese enge
Verflechtung die enge Verflechtung von
Hamas Infrastruktur mit ziviler
Infrastruktur sie merken das ja das ist
ja das ist ja nicht nur dass es
menschliche Schilde sind sondern sind
auch infrastrukturschilde
wird es sehr sehr schwer sein diese
materielle Infrastruktur von Hamas zu
zerschlagen auch wenn sie ich sag mal
die Führungskräfte mehrheitlich aus
auuser Gefecht setzen würden wie auch
immer äh haben Sie Recht die Einstellung
bleibt bloß Einstellung ohne
Organisation nützt nichts ja wenn Sie
also die operative Handlungsfähigkeit
der Organisation Hamas massiv
militärisch schwächchen hat das zunächst
einmal für einen gewissen Zeitraum
durchaus seine Auswirkung aber da sind
wir noch nicht es gibt noch genug
Reserven soweit wir das soweit
vorkriegsschätzungen das uns ja auch
nahgelegt haben was also nun die die
Tausende und Abertausende von Raketen
angeht und weitere
Infanteriewaffen Sprengstoff auch von
den Kämpfern von hier sind es ja wohl
fünfstellige Zahlen 20.000 30.000 sie
haben jetzt Opfer vielleicht in den
hunderten vielleicht in den kleinen
Tausender Zahl das glaube ich aber gar
nicht dass das so schnell so schrecklich
passieren würde das heißt sie hab müssen
sich auch Wochen wenn ich Monate
vergleichbare Kampfhandlung einstellen
in der Theorie ja um in der Tat dann
Hamar personell und
infrastrukturell zu zerstören da bliebe
immer noch der verbreitete sag mal Hass
nicht auf die Gegner aber den müssen sie
halt immer wieder dann organisatorisch
umsetzen
und wenn die Organisation nicht mehr da
wäre ja dann würde das auch deutlich
schwerer möglich sein es wäre
zurückbomben ein zurückkämfen Hamas in
die Zeit vor Gaza wenn Sie wollen als
Hamas nur ein untergrundnetz war aber
nicht ein Territorium besetzt
hatte Herr Konrad lassen Sie uns gerne
einmal schauen auf die Vermittlung
Verhandlung die sie für die Freilassung
des Soldaten gilard Schalit geführt
haben holen Sie mich gerne einmal ab
holen Sie uns gerne einmal ab wie liefen
diese Verhandlungen damals ab und was
hat die aus ihrer Sicht rückblickend
erfolgreich
gemacht ja ich kam ja zu einem relativ
späten Zeitpunkt in die Verhandlung sie
haben zurecht gesagt gilard schalid war
ja 5 Jahre im Gewahrsam von Hamas er
wurde 2006 entführt auch in einem
Vergleich bei einem ambush einem
Überfall allerdings durch einen Tunnel
seine Kameraden wurden seiner Zeit im
Überfall getötet er wurde quasi per
Zufall nach Gaza entführt und befand
sich dann die ganze Zeit
im Gewahrsam so äh israel hat dann über
Ägypten die ersten zweieinhalb Jahre
versucht einen Verhandlungsrahmen zu
schaffen der Rahmen ist auch geschaffen
worden man konnte sich aber über die
Inhalte nicht einigen das heißt also sie
wissen heramas hat letzten Endes eine
gesamtsummer von 1000 Freilassungen
gefordert 450
qualifizierte Häftlinge
sicherheitshäftlinge die sie selber
vorschlagen wollte und darüber hat man
sich heillos zerstritten und in dieser
Situation als Netanyahu 2009 wieder
Premierminister wurde äh bin ich dann
sozusagen vor Deutschland aus
ausgeliehen worden als quasi privater
Vermittler es hat nicht der BND
vermittelt die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland hat nicht vermittelt die
unterhält nämlich keine Beziehungen zu
Hamas die auch schon damals als
terroristische Vereinigung galt sondern
ich wurde aufgrund von früheren anderen
vermittlungserfolgen quasi als
Privatperson ausgeliehen und hatte ein
Mandat von Israel und eben auch ein
Mandat von Hamas um eben einen
Vertragsentwurf zu erarbeiten das haben
wir dann auch geschafft ist aber eine
ganz andere Situation wie sie sehen die
ist nur sehr schwer mit der heutigen zu
vergleichen und gut das andere and ist
wenn sie wollen einfach nur ein elendes
eine shuttled diipomatiie gewesen um
eben mühsam einen Text Listen
zusammenzustellen um dann die Kandidaten
die aus den israelischen Gefängnissen zu
entlassen sein eben zu identifizieren ne
und zwar quasi einfnehmlich nicht und
das haben wir so einigermaßen
hinbekommen allerdings hat Heras zum
Schluss eben noch mal auf einer einem
Zuschlag von
das waren zum Schluss dann 27 äh
besonders belasteten Häftlingen
besonders groß Helden aus ihrer Sicht
bestanden das ließ sich dann erst mit
ägyptischer massiver diplomatischer und
ja politischer Hilfe dann
bewerkstelligen sowohl den Druck auf die
israelische Seite als auch eben auf am
Maß nicht noch mehr zu fordern denn das
Problem ist bei solchen Dingen immer man
kann ja immer noch mal ein Aufschlag
machen noch mal ein Aufschlag zum
Aufschlag nicht das geht ein bisschen
was geht bekanntlich immer nicht und das
war das was has natürlich wollte ein
Maximum herausreizen aus der Tatsache
dass sie einen lebenden israelischen
Soldaten in ihre Gewalt
hat ja jetzt haben sie eben dann 230 240
Israel zivil und Soldaten und das ändert
natürlich die Sachlage ganz besonders
verstehe Herr Konrad wir haben noch eine
Frage bekommen bei Youtube von jmain
jmain fragt welche zukünftigen
diplomatischen kamäle Kanäle so ist es
richtig können denn gegebenenfalls
vermitteln auch aus ihrer Erfahrung
heraus ja im Grunde eigentlich nur
Staaten sie brauchen einen Staat erst
einmal der dessen Geheimdienste oder
dessen Politiker dessen Diplomaten
gesprächsfähig sind sowohl gegenüber der
politischen und militärischen Führung
von Hamas denn wir brauchen beide die
militärische Führung macht nicht immer
das was ihre politische Führung ihnen
sagt besonders weil die im Exil ist und
natürlich gegenüber der israelischen
Regierung derzeit sind das letzten Endes
Qatar wie wir sehen
und es ist Ägypten beides beides Staaten
die über langjährige Beziehungen jetzt
zu Hamas verführen das mag man bedauern
oder auch nicht jetzt ist es natürlich
extrem nützlich äh und das wird wohl
auch der Rahmen sein aus dem sie nicht
rauskommen denkt sie auch daran dass sie
ohne Ägypten einen großen Austausch und
überhaupt in Gaza kaum etwas bewegen
können aufgrund der Tatsache dass
Ägypten eben ähm den massivsten Einfluss
auf Gaza ausüben kann abgesehen von
Israelis und Ägypten eben in der Tat
auch mit als muslimisches Land auch mit
der mit den Muslimbrüdern die dort im
Lande zwar wieder unter Druck stehen
gleich wohl man hat gesprächsgrundlagen
dann hat ein vergleichbaren Zeichensatz
nicht den terroristischen aber den
sprachlichen und
kulturellen jetzt kommt zum Schluss von
mir der obligatorische Blick in die
glaskuge bzw die daraus formulierte
Frage wie welchen Zeithorizont sehen Sie
denn da ist das ja worauf müssen wir uns
einstellen ja also wir müssen jetzt als
erstes ja genau die einfach die
militärische Dynamik sehen ob das sich
eben in der Tat auf einen langfristig
angelegten Konflikt hin entwickelt
langfristig heiß über Wochen kann das da
ist die Frage die kann das Israel quasi
nicht militärisch aber politisch
durchhalten sowohl innen als auch
außenpolitisch ist eine offene Frage da
zeigt die Erfahrung eigentlich eher
nicht aber wir haben jetzt eine neue
Situation es kann auch passieren dass
Hamas selbst um des eigenen Überlebens
willen äh politischen überlebenswell zu
Kompromissen
findet die werden Ihnen aber wenn dann
eben von ägyptischer und katarischer
Seite nah gebracht werden müssen und
Israel muss mitspielen das kann also
dann durchaus wäre aber dann natürlich
nicht das erklärte Ziel von Israel sich
ein für alle Mal dieser Organisation zu
entledigen so und damit haben sie im
Grunde genommen positive Überraschungen
innerhalb von Wochen und
elendes dahinziehen über Monate
mindestens wenn nicht sogar noch L und
denken Sie dar dran es muss ja nicht von
vorin eine Gesamtlösung geben es kann
durchaus sein dass wir erfreuliche
Nachrichten haben mit 50 oder mit 70
oder mit 80 ge wir haben aber
240 das ist natürlich präzedenzlos das
wissen wir nicht insofern müssen wir uns
können wir auf einen schnellen Verlauf
hoffen aber mit einem langen Verlauf
müssen wir rechnen sagt der
sicherheitsperte sicherheitexperte
Gerhard Konrad vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit
und die Antworten heute abend ich
bedanke mich für Ihre Zeit danke soweit
unser ZDF heute live zur Situation der
Geiseln im Gazastreifen aktuelle Infos
findet ihr dazu wie immer in der zdr fte
App danke euch fürs zuschauen danke fürs
kommentieren und Fragen stellen und bis
zum nächsten Mal tschü
TÜ